I was wondering what is now uh your
position in the grand stour for the
moment uh after the previous events and
what are you looking forward to achieve
let's say during those two events yeah I
think I'm in a pretty reasonable spot to
finish in the top three I'd say so it's
also very important for me to try to
qualify for next year's grandchester so
actually now that you mention it there's
quite a lot of steak for for me for
speak about it for sure yes because it's
it's very difficult to get into the
grandchester the spots are very limited
and uh uh there are you know many
players who are joining also we got uh
Richard report and Yan Christof Duda who
represent Europe uh represent Poland and
Romania respectively so you really have
to fight your way for it